[Music]
yeah hello my name is aim doberan I'm
the deputy director general for research
of the international rice Research
Institute or Erie and the gentleman
besides me here is Lee wild he's the
head of our experimental station and
what we want to do with you in the next
few months is actually learn how to grow
a crop of rice not just any crop of rice
we want to do it in the best possible
manner we can think of you now we are
scientists so we do a lot of research
and we believe that we know a lot about
rice and how to grow it in different
parts of the world and we have lots of
recommendations for farmers and
extension workers we often call them
best management practices you can find
them on on the internet on our knowledge
bank and extension materials in books
and scientific papers but what we really
really want to do is try to practice
what we preach because often we as
scientist may come up with uh things
that you know don't really work in
practice or sometimes you wonder why
aren't people using them so that's why
Lee and I have decided well why don't we
do it ourselves as much as we can do our
ourselves because some of the things we
may not be really qualified to do but
we'll try okay we will we will be
[Music]
qualified well this is day one of the
great challenge so and our first job
today is to level the field now Lee why
is leveling the field so important and
how do we do
this for wet seed rice you're dealing
with a with a Seedling that is 2 days
old young and very fragile and there's
the two most important criteria you've
got to meet early are water control and
weed control and in some ways they're
one and the
same so by leveling you can ensure that
each each seedling has a consistent
amount of water or a consistent lack of
water depending on what you're trying to
achieve at the
time so we really think leveling the
field is the very first and most
important step probably to get a good
crop established particularly if it's
wet seated dries as we want to do in our
agom challenge this
year yes we're targeting a high yield
and for a high yield we need a good
establishment density we need a good
number of plants in the field so we need
a good survival of and and uh growing of
the the seeds that we we will put out
with the drum seeder in 2 days time and
leveling is definitely the found
Foundation upon which a good high yield
is
built when you grow rice of course as a
farmer you have to choose a variety to
grow so we have chose in a variety
called n RC
222 or in the Philippines it's also
called locally TU beun 18 but it is
actually an eerie variety so it has also
the Eerie designation IR r
i54 now why did we choose this it can
yield with good management easily six
seven maybe even more tons per heor and
it is a relatively new variety we play a
lot of emphasis on this because more
recently released varieties are better
adapted to the current climate and they
can therefore have better adaptation to
the yield potential situation the
environment that we have nowadays this
variety was released in 2010 and that
just that factor using a more recent
variety can often give a yeld advantage
of 5 to 10% well we began with certified
seed now this seed has been germination
germination tested and it tested it
greater than
90% uh it was soaked uh put in water 36
36 hours ago and then drained about 16
or 17 hours ago and incubated for that
length of time it's it's got a short uh
route and even on some it's got a short
uh shoot
already so this is about
ideal for for using a drum cater that
we'll we'll touch on shortly the rout
and shoot could be a little bit longer
and it' still be okay so we've got a few
hours to spare which might be helpful
yeah um and the seed is is uh ready
what are we going to do
Lee I suspect the conclusion is we're
not going to drum
suit um this is the depth of our
mud so as such the the wheels of the
drum seeder sink too far into the mud
and hence the the metering units sit on
the mud and fail to function as metering
units do we do the a few a few met out
ahead once you okay just control control
just little little little little little
FES like like this you want to you do
like that yeah
see okay Lee on a scale 1 to 10 uh what
do you think we've accomplished in terms
of spreading our seed uniformally I
think when we started the field we were
barely five but overall I think I'd give
us a seven or an eight the uniformity is
quite good uh we're aiming for a plant
density of 50 plants a square meter and
there's plenty of seeds in the field
spread uniformly to achieve just that we
can lose a few seeds and we'll still be
t i i I had a lot of trouble initially I
was I think looking too much on the
ground trying to sprinkle seed in little
patches you know and but later I think I
got the swing you know like the broad
swing looking straight ahead walking and
through I'm I'm quite hopeful that I
improved over time but uh we'll see in
the week I guess what emerges
what we have here is an area that's
that's representative of the the higher
areas of the fields the areas that were
that were well drained so this probably
represents 50 to 60% of the
field the the drainage was good the
access to oxygen for the developing seed
has been good it's germinated quickly
and strongly it's got uh a green shoot
very quickly and its third Leaf is
already appearing this is
uh wet direct seeding as it should be
done these plants are
happy now what we have here is an area
that's representative of the the
intermediate Zone shall I say when we
seated it was too wet it was a little
bit too wet and gradually during the
week it gradually dried out but it was
still wetter than we'd like it to be and
you can see the seedlings are much
smaller they've had to fight for
survival for much of the week but they
are establishing and they'll be okay
even though they're slow The
Establishment density is lower but
overall it's an acceptable
result so the seedlings were
unhappy but now they're
okay what we have here is an area
representative of are of complete
failure the area areas like this may be
five somewhere between 5 and 10% of the
field stayed wet all week they've only
just become
dry uh that was too long for the rice
plants so here we have an area that's
completely devoid of rice seedlings all
the rice seeds have
died so what we have is an uneven feel
fi a non-uniform field the drier areas
have grown really well the intermediate
areas have grown okay they'll be okay
but the wetter
areas uh have been complete failures so
5 to 10% of the field we're going to
recede to give it that second chance
true uh being seated almost a week later
will mean it matures a little later but
rice does have a habit of catching up by
the time you get to flowering and
harvest so I'm not that
concerned I think in hindsight we were
seduced by technology we looked to the
laser leveling laser guided ler
equipment when in hindsight I think the
small equipment the the equipment
invented here in the Philippines would
have given us a More Level field so um
don't always assume the high-tech path
is the most effective one so we're
reating small areas just the wetter
areas the the drier areas where the rice
is okay that soil is now too dry it
won't uh seed successfully the rice
Roots won't penetrate the soil so
there's no point putting seed there
anyway we're focusing purely on those
small very wet areas with no rice in
them at
all now I'm also thinking over here
looking around here there's an area with
a rat fence over to our to my left and
now that that can be good because
if you do have a rat problem last year
there was a rat problem just here it's
good to have what we call a trap crop
where you plant an area early about 2 to
3 weeks early and then have traps with
multile capture traps entrances right
there so the rats are go in but can't
get back out again particularly after
the fellow period the rats there's big
disturbance during the fellow period And
The Working of the soil so the rats then
get move out of get moved to the edges
and they agregate and that's the best
time to manage them how we have here
trappy the rat and trappy is is used
often when I talk to Farmers and we will
show that they will enter into the Trap
here and he'll Force his way through and
rats yeah trap is big but see how they
sort of crunch down and rats can do that
as well the only thing that limits a rat
they they can disate their shoulder
shoulders what it's the width of their
head which indicates as the how big the
the hole is that can get in and with a
mouse you push a finger in a mouse can
get into a hole with a rat it's more
sort of a probably a large thumb so it's
usually about 12 mm if you got a hole
bigger than that then the rats can get
through and so often you know you don't
need a very big opening here the rats
will force their way through what do we
know about birds and their interactions
with suited R here in the Philippines
and elsewhere in Asia often it's it's
using of what you've got here the flags
to just caus a bit of of disturbance not
I have seen not far from here where they
have a little like a little windmill a
little ratchet on it making a noise and
that's suppos to keep the birds away as
well so it's it's looking at at noise as
a
deterrent we came up after many years of
research with tools that farmers and
extension brokers can use and I'm going
to use one of these tools here so what I
have here is a small tablet computer it
runs the Android system and we have on
this little
tablet uh an application or app as
they're called nowadays uh that we
released uh last year for farmers in the
Philippines as a first example it's
called nutrient manager rice or
sometimes also nutrient manager
mobile and it's very simple to use it's
all touch screen here as you can see if
you don't have a Android smartphone like
this you can also use it through a
normal phone and call a toll-free number
in the Philippines and all it does it's
asking you 12 13 14 questions about your
field so after I've done all this voila
comes out a fertilizer recommendation
[Music]
this is a horrible
S one of the first issues with water
management is wet seated rice currently
is really sensitive to water if you have
too much water the the seeds die and uh
so that's why you need really good
leveling and secondly it's why we really
need to get anob germination tolerance
into rice seeds so that the technology
is less difficult and and less risky for
Farmers so this field was lucky after it
was established there was where a few
showers of rain which kept it going
nicely I don't think it's been irrigated
yet but I could just of flying fer and
so the ideal thing next will be to
irrigate to wash the fertilizer into the
soil uh one way to reduce the amount of
irrigation water we apply to rice is to
do what we call alternate wetting and
drying so this means we flood the field
then we let the water disappear we let
the surface dry down and then we re
irrigate
again and that anybody can do alternate
wetting and drying but the question is
how do you do it safely so that that you
don't lose any yield because rice is so
sensitive to Too Much
drying so over the years ER has done a
lot of research and and they've found
that if we let at the soil dry down
below about 10 or 15 kilop pascals uh
soil soil water tension at about 15 cm
below the soil surface the rice suffers
but 10 or 15 killer pascals probably
doesn't mean anything to you and it
doesn't mean anything to Farmers some
really nice work with this really simple
field water tube which just shows you
where the water table is you could pull
it out I think yeah I'm P out can yeah
yeah 15 cm from the bottom so you should
push it into the mark you go a little
bit further it doesn't matter okay how
often do we think I need to come out and
check
the well it depends on the weather for a
start and uh it's but at least once a
week right tce once a week yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
now today we're measuring the plant
density in the field the plants have
started to tiller so it's getting a
little bit difficult to count but it's
still
okay I'm using a 0.1 squ M or 1/10 of a
square m ring manufactured from some
garden hose I stole from my
wife uh throw the ring at random
preferably over your shoulder that
guarantees fairly random and it's
several locations so you get it
representative of the
field and the results we got uh averaged
about 13 plants per per ring or 130
plants per square met but the lowest was
one plant per ring and the highest was
32 so there's a lot of variation but I
still think we're
okay uh Pinar do we need to worry about
insect at this early stage do we need to
spray no why not at this stage the the
insect damage is can be completely
compensated for by the plant so normally
the things you get at the early stage
are things like Leaf
folder little bit of leaf folder and wh
maggot wh maggot actually is the biggest
problem this time of year but as the
plant grows it just it just disappears
because the plant as the leaves get
thicker the maggots can't actually eat
the leaf but you know I I keep woring I
see things on the leav like this here
and know some chewed on it this is a wh
maggot that's a wh maget in there
nothing to worry about no problem no
problem it is yeah in fact this is even
light it's not even uh you know a normal
infestation of world
magget what is this here there's a some
egg M on it here whatever yeah these are
these are probably some sort of paracoid
that has sorts of wasp cocoon and these
are beneficial again so it's good news
uh these will fly off there about 40 of
them there so they'll fly off then and
parasitize things like Leaf folder um
larve or um other caterpillars so
they're again a beneficial
insect fin bar I saw already saw a few
lady Beatles is what I would call them
are they are they playing much of a role
at this early St they're also very
important they're also feeding on on the
natural of the the herbivore insights so
they eat eggs mainly um also good uh
predators of apids and also the
dragonfly there's a lot of dragonfly
flying around one of the things when you
think about insects and rice you have to
remember that in the water another
problem generated by rice is mosquitoes
and the dragonfly Lara live in the water
they have a very big uh strong jaw and
they pre on the dragon on the uh
mosquito larae so they're keeping your
mosquitoes down so really there's a
whole ecosystem here functioning to keep
everything in order I mean one really
has to look hard to see all these things
I see a little spider web here and which
some some little insects are caught in
there what are those these are those
that are flying around these are
the decomposer so they're again
uh beneficial and spiders are very
important uh predators of things like
plant oppers mainly plant Hoppers so but
but you know when I look around I see
lots of crits here know insects of all
kinds of little things flying or
crawling or so is that one of the
reasons that some Farmers think they
have to spray because they see all these
insects but a lot of people don't
understand what they these insects are
doing so a lot of people when they see
these swarms of midges for example that
are decomposing the the material they
think it's a PL and they'll spray uh the
same with the wh maget one of the
biggest problems with world maget is
that it it induces Farmers to spray but
we never see any yield reduction the
same with um uh Leaf folder
[Music]
now our crop is finally starting to
exert itself it's within a week of
Maximum tillering so it's it's growing
quite strongly now and a lot of those
gaps that we've had to live with for
several weeks are finally starting to
fill in so we're feeling
better uh this week we're going to take
the opportunity to talk about uh what I
would call the biotic influences on the
crop and making an assessment of it so
that's how uh animals plants funguses
invol viruses how how they're
interacting with the crop both
beneficial and not beneficial I have
with me here Nancy Castillo who uh who
is a specialist in assessing uh rice
crops for for the biotic influences and
the level of injury that's coming from
it and Nancy and I will will step
through the process of assessing the
rice crop for insects for um for weeds
for and for dis diseases both from
viruses and funguses so uh in we go so
next week what we intend to do is that
we will be collecting data on injuries
caused by animal pest animal pest uh uh
refer to insect pest snails and rats and
then we will be also assessing injuries
caused by
diseases um viral disease bacterial
diseases and um
um fungal diseases and then we will be
also uh assessing uh injuries caused by
weeds since this is direct seeded rice
so we have here a quadrant what we call
as a We call we we consider some kind of
a magic weapon so this is equivalent to
one heel and transplanted rice so
we we would actually be sampling um for
for diseases and in and uh and uh insect
injuries we will be using um 10
quadrants we be sampling from 10
quadrants and then we would be also uh
taking uh um we will be sampling weeds
from three areas each area would be
about 1 M by 1 M so we would be
assessing weeds relative to the height
of the canopy and we will be recording
the type of weeds that we will find so
we have a sweep net yes this is a sweep
net we use this for uh counting the
flying insects in this case mainly Green
Leaf HPP
ERS uh Green Leaf Hopper is the vector
of tongro for the topping method we have
this small a pan here with water it has
a little detergent and we use it for
counting sucking insects like uh plant
Hoppers white back plant Hoppers Brown
plant Hoppers and in other in in the
surveys we do in other parts of the
Philippines we also catch rice bugs okay
okay um
black bugs rather so so with these these
magic weapons next week when the crop
reaches the stage of Maximum tillering
yeah you'll make an assessment uh
according to our yeah our data sheet and
then again uh in the reproductive stage
in in the grain filling and mature
mature stage uh we'll make another
assessment that should give us a good
idea of what biological things have done
uh both for and against our our rice
crop
yeah it's now about 45 days after sewing
so as you can see uh the crop starts
elongating so we have hit pretty much
the the end of the tillering and um it's
now time
for the crop to develop more biomass so
you can see it's got a quite a few nice
looking tillers here in this place and
stem starts allocating now so we're
coming then gradually closer to what
will then be the next stage pacle
initiation when they uh the next thing
that we we also did today like we said
last week already ny's team just uh went
through around here and they just did an
assessment of all the uh different kinds
of crop damage might have had so
diseases insects weeds Even Rats so
we'll see what they have found out but
they went across the whole field and
stopped at about 30 locations and assess
what what we've got there so that'll be
interesting information and a bit more
objective than what we saw ourselves
sometimes we are getting biased by
thinking okay we've got this problem and
this problem this problem but they've
done it in a very systematic Manner and
we will see uh what they have
so but when you just sort of look around
uh the whole field here so from the
distance uh it starts looking actually
quite Okay so we've got a pretty good uh
dense uh green canopy building up so if
we can supports us now with enough
nutrients and good water management and
we don't run into more best problems we
should be okay
[Music]
60 days after sewing so the crop is uh
moving into heading stage you can see
it's getting quite tall so what I'm
doing here today is I'm going to check
whether we need a little bit more
nitrogen so just looking at it I have
the feeling that there are some places
where it gets a little bit yellowish and
we know that right now we need a lot of
nitrogen because the picles are formed
and we want to make sure that there's no
limitation of that important nutrient so
the tool that I'm using for this is this
uh Leaf color Shard which has four
different shades of green and uh it
should guide me whether I need an extra
little bit of nitrogen or not so what
I'm basically doing is I'm walking
through the field and I've been taking
about 15 20 readings at different places
and whenever I hit the spot I'll
basically take a leaf the uppermost Leaf
I'll put it on the chart in the middle
of the leaf and I find the green shade
that matches the color of the leaf uh
best so this one here is matching
perfectly the shade number three and
that basically tells us that we're
getting a little a bit low already yeah
but I have to take of course many
readings because there's some
variability in the
Lea and I've done this now so I've just
finished this uh and I've concluded that
on average my Leaf color chart reading
is actually less than three so it's
between 2.5 and three in many cases so
that's why I've decided to put on an
extra amount of about 25 kg of nitrogen
as Ura at this stage and that should
probably complete our whole fertilizer
application regime other than that at
this stake of the crop there is really
nothing we can do at this point I saw
some Wheats coming up here and there uh
no insect damage really that I'm worried
about right now so our decision to not
spray any insecticide so far seems to
work out and the rest now we need to
wait and hope for more sunshin so that
hopefully we'll still get some kind of
decent yeld
[Music]
so we start with a visual estimate of of
how ready the crop is and we we we first
look at the the proportion of yellow
grains the proportion of straw yellow
grains now Martin has suggested an ideal
amount for Harvest would be 80% yellow
now in front of me here we always have a
issue as to whether it's representative
or not it's
probably 50 to 60% yellow something of
that order it's not not quite ready
yet now a more objective and
professional way to assess how uh how
ready the crop is will be to measure its
moisture content yep and this is one way
to do that this is a moist meter So-Cal
moist meter it measures the resistance
of the crop which is uh basically
dependent on the moisture content and
you have a small sample tray so you take
a a sample from a panicle at least at
80% of the of the grains should be STW
yellow that basically says 80% of one
panicker getting representative is
always a challenge there's no a
challenge so so uh you take a small
sample like this fill it in there and
then uh what you do with this instrument
basically you crush it oops can I give
you this it you turn the knob and crush
it turn it all the way to the end and
then uh you measure the resistance and
that gets translated in the reading of
the moisture content and it this case
it's 21.6% now what we're going to do is
mix The Greener one I've I've I've
harvested and because this is a very
small sample it's not really
representative neither for small plot
nor for the field so what you have to do
is you have to in one location you
should to different at least three
different
measurements so now in this sample for
example you have a lot more green grains
than in the previous one so the reading
should be a lot higher
27.9% and you would take at least three
samples and then you have a button here
where you can average the readings and
then you get the average reading for
that uh location and then what you have
to do is basically also measure in a
representative way in the field because
the the crop doesn't mature evenly
everywhere in the
field so Le is just getting a sample
from another location doing my best to
stay on my feet trying to find a green
[Music]
one it's probably semi
respectable yeah so there's still a lot
of straw particles in there not very
well thresh um what you want to have is
only grains in
there and it should be basically just
one layer of grains or a little bit more
than that
so we crush it
again take our
reading
27.7 and we can't do an average because
I just did that and we only have one
more reading in the
moment so it's well and truly above 24
might be 27 28 29 something like that
yeah in there we measured around up to
30% so so I think it's probably around
28 29 we're facing the final tricky
decision to irrigate
or not to irrigate that is the question
so we're considering how moist the soil
is now how moist is the soil now moist
right we're considering what the
weather's like what's the weather like
hot dry and we're considering how long
we'd expect until we Harvest and our
consensus is about
10 days to 2 weeks something of that
range it'll be close to 2 weeks time
before you're back to do the
D so we need this to last to to finish
properly I think it needs the two
weeks but it's moist it's heavy clay and
we do want our combine to stay on the
ground not to explore the
underground I
vote keep it
dry yeah I would have if it was an
experiment and I knew that we would be
doing hand harvesting I would put on
another irrigation just for safety but
we need to figure out that we have to
come in with a combine and so the
carrying capacity of that soil will be
the deciding factor and we can't delay
Harvest because we see some lodging
coming in so I go with the majority vote
yeah I agree so no more irrigation let's
see but I pray for a little bit of rain
tonight
maybe well on racing pattern I think
you'll probably have that have that wish
granted so there we have it we won't
irrigate again and we'll it'll be in
approximately 2 weeks we'll come back
and harvest about my
second yeah I was on a trip last week
and then Lee sent me a note that we had
70% lodging to when I came back uh
yesterday afternoon the first thing I
did was rush out to the field and then
this is what I saw that's a lot more
than 70% so it's basically a complete
mess now
lodging uh I guess I can be many reasons
for this but probably the primary reason
is uh we've had a broadcast Zone crop
which is not anchored very deep in the
in the saw we
had unnecessary rain now I would say
unnecessary rain and you can see it's
all lodging in One Direction here so we
must have had some wind too I don't
think we had too much nitrogen although
that obviously sometimes contributes too
so what we're going to do now Lee we're
going to harvest it so as I explained in
in an earlier clip there's one one
crucial Advantage if we if we take this
section of crop here it's
lodged but there's still some air space
under the crop there's 3 or 4 in of of
air space under there and that's a
crucial difference the combine the
combine won't have too much trouble as
long as we're careful
um if it gets flatter than that then we
are in real trouble and that's that's
the concern ideally we probably should
wait one more day but there's already
threatening looking clouds over there so
I think it might be time to act before
it gets any worse yeah and we had
another rain yesterday afternoon so I'm
getting nervous too it is still quite
wet underneath here but uh as long as we
get through with the combine and pull it
up well I think we have no choice let's
try it
the whole yeah I think we need to get a
initial cut yeah yeah initial cut and
then after that you could do yeah you
could have
some operation it is easy did you just
you just POS I know I
know yeah so that's that's nice not
perfect but nice
I had a lot of trouble going that
[Music]
way we've harvested the rice now we're
at the business end
where we Mill the rice into a product to
eat so uh the first thing that happened
after we harvested the rice is we took
it to dry it it was at a moisture
content of about 21% from memory and we
took it and dried it in a flatbed dryer
down to a moisture of about 14% so
Mountain's going to uh measure the
moisture content of a sample before our
eyes and hopefully it's what our climate
is yeah so I can't actually measure the
sample uh that that has been in the mill
because uh it's already mil but I have
another sample here and uh the ideal
moisture content for for Milling is
between 13 and
14% and uh so the first step would
basically be to measure the moisture
content and this is an example for a
moisture meter the Eerie moisture meter
you you put a small sample of grains in
there and then you crush them and then
by measuring the resistance it gives you
the moer content and this uh basically
tells you that the the sample that we
have is still too wet we couldn't use
that for Milling so that's more than 16%
it's more more than 14% than in this
case and and uh basically this would
also tell us if it's right for Milling
between 12 and 14% or whether it's right
for seeds what happens if you Mill it
when it's wetter than 14% if you Mill it
wet then the grain is very soft and and
we get a lot of damage in the in the
Rice Mill by uh basically the the
machines are crashing crushing the
grains and and so you're Milling would
be a lot lower and what if it's too dry
if it's too dry then it's too brittle
and again you get uh because of
mechanical stress you get more cracking
uh because it's so brittle and again you
get more more losses okay okay and for
the drying there are different options
uh the this grain was dried in the
flatbed dryer uh and but the flatbed
dryers are very simple technology that
can be locally produced and produces
reasonably good quality but then there
also more sophisticated dryers like we
have one over there which is a so-called
recirculating batch dryer which allows
us to produce really the optimum quality
of of the Patty before we do the Milling
after the the grain has been
dried uh to the appropriate moisture
content it's it's then delivered to the
mill and the first stage is the
dehulling where we have two rubber
rollers set at a a very close clearance
to each
other and one roller is traveling just a
little bit slower than the other roller
and that that abrasion motion that that
pins motion
removes the husk from the rice it then
goes on to a gravity table which then in
a in a horizontal reciprocating motion
uh it's on a slight angle and that
successfully removes the the held rice
the H brown rice from the rice that was
not successfully helded and the rice
that was not successfully H goes back to
be DEH
again after that it goes through three
stages of
polishing an abrasion stone
polisher a friction polisher and then
you also have a choice of a Mist
polisher if you want that final shall I
call it
Sheen uh for a really quality uh quality
high quality product that really looks
as desirable as it tastes and there's
one final process after the polishing
process it's then it's then graded for
size both through a rotary sifter
and through a length greater and that
separates the whole rice from the broken
rice the final stage in a sophisticated
Rice Mill is the color sort which is an
ingenious piece of technology that that
runs uh streams of of of milled rice
grain in a in a single grain stream uh
there's there's sensors that sense the
color of individual grains and if the
color does not is not white enough
basically that could be from poor
Milling it could be because it's a
foreign object like a stone there's
nothing as much fun as a stone in your
rice uh a a short sharp jet of
compressed air will remove the Grain and
so the those that final high standard
sorting processes is quite a common
process in in high standard rice meals
and then hence you have the finished
product uh whole grain WellMed rice with
a known quantity of brokens in it and
that's really the objective of the whole
process
[Music]
the good news is we made a profit that's
good not a huge profit but a
profit so we grew 5.24 tons to the
hectare of rice and we valued it at 14
pasos per kilogram here in the
Philippines which is equivalent to about
30 us cents or
$300 per ton of Patty rice in summary I
have these figures are particularly
visible to the film we earned $440 from
the field we spent $350 growing it so we
made according to this
$84 in
profit which at least pice for the
coffee we're drinking and a fair bit
more well that's for the field but uh if
we extrapolate this to a whole Hector
which is what a normal farmer would
probably have so that's a net profit of
per
Hector so is that a normal profit is
that what a farmer would be happy I
think it's uh um
probably quite common particularly if
you have deep well irrigation to and
pumping cost to cover yeah if you are an
irrigated Farmer in the Philippines who
um has access to Canal water of
irrigation scheme steam water the
typical profit is probably more like
$500 per Hector and that's what I
remember measuring once so we are below
that but that's primarily really the
reason um is because of the high
irrigation cost which probably explains
as you look across the rice growing
world that dry season rice is generally
confined to those locations where water
is easy and cheap to access yeah it has
to do exactly that yeah good I think
that wraps it up um we've not become
rich at least we haven't lost money I
think we've learned a lot yeah we have
so we'll promise to do better next time
right Cheers Cheers
[Music]
o